Well,
there's movies like that too,
right?
There's movies about really important subjects that are terrible movies.
Like how many
caused me to think that it's are really,
really important subject.
It probably is a terrible movie.
Yeah,
most likely.
Why do I think that?
Right?
Well,
there's no way to really get an important subject and boil it down to two hours.
Oh,
I didn't think of that.
I mean,
give me two hours
and employ your right jacket.
Yeah,
I mean,
especially like,
one thing that drives me crazy is when they take liberties with someone's
biography,
like if they would do a biography on someone's life and they change things
around or add things to it for theatrical flair.
Is She the Queen Movie?
No,
I did not see it yet.
I haven't seen it either.
I heard it's very good though.
You heard it's very good.
Did you ask the person who told you that why it's good?
Um,
yes.
Yes.
And what did they share?
They said the,
first of all,
the guy who plays Freddie Mercury apparently is brilliant in it.
And it said they,
Shane originally had they seen Freddie lies?
No,
not live.
I saw Freddy live at the forum.
I was in the maybe 20th row six in when Bohemian rhapsody had just come out.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
I saw him in his absolute,
that is major,
major prime there.
So I'm very curious as to,
well stage craft is one thing,
but what Freddie was and what he brought was way more than what you saw on
stage.
Yeah.
Fella.
What was he bringing?
Well,
his sensibilities in terms of music weren't just three core origin and attitude.
And they'll fall for that shit either.
If Keith ever sits here and tries,
that shit is all wrong.
You just need three,
three goals in an attitude.
Yeah.
And you need to know the inversions of each one.
All seven modal and fuck you Keith,
because he does know all those and the trick tunings and whatever.
Um,
Freddy brought a whole wealth of listening to different kinds of music,
whether it was orchestral big band,
Bistro you mean?
Nah,
that's bestrode uh,
uh,
what do you call it?
Music,
music,
that small,
uh,
something you might hear in a coffee shop in France.
Well,
his music was so different.
His singing was so different than anything else from his era.
But you listen to,
we are the champions.
He didn't try to sing black.
Okay.
Sang Freddie Mercury.
We Shang European nonblack what?
We're very used to,
even in country.
I had a very famous black producer,
African American producer,
shading me,
David Lee.
Do you know what it means to be a black man in the United States today?
Hash.
Every time I step up to the mic,
I try.
That's what I grew up with.
Trying to sound like meltdown and trying to sound like Wilson Pickett.
Try to sound like an on and on that,
that you know that voter block had such an impact on music,
much less the overall culture.
Right.